Speaker 1: Today.
We're going to be speaking with Sheila Heen,
who's a Harvard Law School professor, founder
of Triad Consulting, and also coauthor of
the New York Times bestsellers Difficult Conversations,
as well as thanks for the feedback.
A Sheila, it's really great to have you on
today.
Speaker 5: I'm delighted to be here.
Speaker 1: So I've every week I get questions
from people in my audience.
I have this very big political disagreement
with my mom and I want to know how to handle
it.
Or I have this difficult situation with my
coworkers politically and I want to know how
to handle it.
And people ask me for advice.
And one of the first things I say is, well,
to figure out the right path forward, you
kind of first have to think about what you
want the outcome to be.
In other words, in a political disagreement
with your mom, what's more important, proving
her wrong or maintaining a relationship with
your mom, for example, depending on what what
you expect might happen?
So can you kind of open up by giving us a
basic framework in terms of how to think generally
about some of these difficult conversations
that people sometimes have.
Speaker 5: Have sort of way?
And and David, I think you're right on the
money, meaning I think one of the core questions
is, what is my purpose in having a conversation?
Because if my purpose is to prove her wrong,
that that is not necessarily going to change
her mind.
You may have noticed that true.
Right.
Because it's totally clear to you that you
have proven her wrong and yet her views persist.
Right.
And so I think that's part of the struggle,
which is that I actually think that there
are things that are hard about just being
in relationship with someone who holds a view
that you find incredibly disturbing, upsetting,
wrongheaded, foolish, uninformed.
Should we keep going?
Right.
Speaker 1: All those things.
Yeah, right.
Right.
And it's important also, because there's a
range of the example I give often is when
people say, are you friends with like radical
right people?
For example, I'll say, listen, if someone
thinks the tax rate should be two points lower
than I do, it's not a big deal.
It's just a disagreement.
And we can kind of just work through that.
It's not really going to affect too many things
about my ability to relate to them.
If they believe there's a secret cabal of
Jews controlling every aspect of, you know,
where I that's going to be a little bit different
in terms of our ability to relate to each
other.
So it seems like that context is important,
too.
Speaker 5: I think that that's exactly right
and.
And so I think what we're talking about are
views that feel like they share at the core
of who we are.
Speaker 1: Yes.
Speaker 5: Or that suggest a threat to something
that we hold really dear.
And so in this weird way, there's like an
identity issue that comes with like, how could
I being who I am and what I care about and
what I want people to see about who I am and
respect about who I am?
How could I be?
Fill in the blank.
Friends with family, with neighbors, with
coworkers.
With this person who the at least the caricature
of the view that they hold in some way invalidates
dismisses or oppresses something that really
matters to me about who I am.
And just that that identity quake that comes
with that question, I think is why we feel
like we need to have a conversation with them.
Right.
Speaker 1: And what's what would thinking
of techniques?
You know, sometimes it'll be like, hey, we
need to talk.
Or You said something that really offended
me, starting with how one felt.
There's all these different tactics that that
are often mentioned.
Is there some universal best way to kind of
start some of these conversations, or does
it really depend on who the person is and
what you're going to talk about?
Speaker 5: So I think that the thing that
it depends most on is negotiating with yourself
about your purpose.
Yeah.
So for instance, the couple of examples that
you just gave, if they just said something
or did something that I want to raise, well
then there is a purpose to the conversation.
And my purpose would be I want to share with
you sort of what impact that had for me or
why I found it upsetting or frustrating, or
that you're not really understanding something
that feels important to me for you to understand.
Right.
So my purpose is actually to share something
with you and to feel heard.
Well, that's a purpose I might be able to
achieve.
Right.
Speaker 1: Right.
Speaker 5: And if I've got my purpose aligned
with something that feels realistic, well,
then I can start by just sharing that purpose.
Like, Hey, whether or not you agree, I want
you to understand why this matters to me.
That would be a great purpose.
And depending on the relationship, they may
or may not say like, okay, or they may start
explaining why you're wrong.
Speaker 1: Right?
Yeah.
You know, when I spoke to one, I spoke to
someone who has hired and fired lots of people.
And I think this will be kind of parallel
to what we're talking about.
And he said one of the things he doesn't like,
which he did early in his career when you
would have to fire someone, is he would bring
them in and he would go listen.
So I want to talk because things haven't been
going so well lately.
And then the employee might say they haven't.
I think things have been going fine.
You're already derailed, right.
And you're kind of trying to back up.
And so his his thing was he would go, listen,
thanks for meeting with me.
We're going to have to let you go.
Let me explain to you why.
And then you're putting out front that there
is a decision and there's a reality here.
And now it's just a matter of kind of thinking
it through and talking it through.
Is that where does that fit into the techniques
that you think can be useful?
And is there something about that, too?
Instead of listen.
Remember the other day when we were talking
about I think.
No, I don't remember that.
Just saying we we had a conversation that
left me feeling really upset with you.
And I want to tell you what happened.
I want to.
Is there something about that as a technique?
Speaker 5: Totally.
Totally.
So.
So one of the things that you're describing
is what we would call a bad news conversation.
Hmm.
Like there's something that has been decided,
or there's something that matters to me.
And the purpose of this conversation is partly
to let you know that.
Yeah, and if the person conversations to let
you know that, then I need to put the bad
news upfront.
And what's funny is that if you ask people
if somebody has bad news for you or needs
to tell you something important, what what
are your requests of them?
Yeah.
Almost everybody says, like, just tell me
upfront.
Like, don't tiptoe into it or hide the ball
or make me guess.
But then when we're on the other side of the
conversation, we ease into it.
I've watched someone try to fire someone by
asking them questions.
Speaker 3: Right.
Speaker 5: But don't you think you'd be better
off, you know, in a different organization
and.
Speaker 1: Not really know.
Speaker 5: It was a friend of theirs?
Right.
So we do it because because of some of the
identity stuff I was talking about.
Like, I'm not the kind of person who hurts
people's feelings.
I'm not the kind of person who treats someone
unfairly.
And and that's why a lot of getting ready
to have an important conversation means negotiate
with yourself, like, well, what's true?
You might hurt their feelings.
Yeah, let's.
Maybe you are sensitive and maybe that's okay.
And you need to let them know, like, look,
this is just a topic on which I am sensitive.
Yeah, we don't argue about whether I'm normal,
sensitive or oversensitive or you're insensitive.
But if we're going to be in relationship with
each other, this is where we're at.
Speaker 1: One of the other situations that
often comes up in the political space, and
this is less about people in my audience,
but more about some of the people that I talk
about politicians or public figures is allegations
are often made against people of all different
kinds.
And then often there's like an instant evaluation
of how an individual reacts when accused of
something.
And unfortunately, what can be difficult about
it is no matter how you react, it's sort of
seen as though like, of course, that's what
being what's being said, you know, and whether
the allegation is of some kind of criminality.
We've seen this in the context of the MeToo
movement, you know, all sorts of allegations.
And if people say, I absolutely didn't do
that, the reaction can often be, well, that's
what everybody would say, at least initially.
Right.
Or most most people would.
Or you kind of get the idea when there are
accusations being hurled at you.
What are some of the ways that are better
to respond maybe than what we often see?
Speaker 5: Well, so I'll give an answer that
I actually learned from someone else.
So years ago we were doing a program in collaboration
with another group, and the other group included
people who did internal investigations within
the CIA, FBI, etc.
And so what they were teaching was how to
read signals that someone might not be giving
you the straight story.
Speaker 1: Yep.
Speaker 5: So one of the things that I learned
from them is that one of the most common red
flags is what's called a protest answer.
Speaker 1: Mm hmm.
Speaker 5: So if you accuse me of fill in
the blank, rather than saying I absolutely
did not do that, the person says, I can't
even believe you would ask me that.
Speaker 1: Mm.
Speaker 5: I can't even believe you would
have the nerve to, etc., etc..
So what's interesting is not that if I'm a
truthful person and I didn't do what's being
accused, that I wouldn't be horrified that
you're even asking or suspecting me.
But what they want to say is, if you are innocent
and telling the truth, the truth is your friend.
So the first thing you're going to blurt out
is the truth, which is like, of course not.
Then you can add, I can't even believe you're
asking me that.
So.
So what's interesting is that you feel if
you're on the, the being accused side of it,
you feel both things.
And it can be tempting to think like, I shouldn't
even have to say I didn't do it, but do say
that you didn't do it right.
Speaker 1: So like a reaction, like, why would
I do that?
That might be where we say, well, you're not
really denying it.
I mean, is that sort of.
Speaker 5: Nonresponsive to the question?
Speaker 1: Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Speaker 5: Yeah, yeah.
The other observation that I learned from
them was that the biggest mistake we make
if we suspect something is going on is that
we don't ask the direct question.
Speaker 1: Right?
Speaker 5: Right.
And they're like, just ask the direct question
and get a direct answer one way or another.
And it's not that that proves anything.
Like you can't be a human lie detector, but
is at least a flag to say like, oh, you might
want to look into it a little bit more.
Speaker 1: Yeah.
In, in police interviewing techniques, which
I've read about a bit.
One of the things that's often said and you
know, whether these things are always true
or mostly true, I guess it depends depends
on circumstances.
But it's when you're interviewing a truly
innocent suspect, they will typically get
really mad.
As you continue to imply or suggest that they
did something, they will genuinely get mad
that they are being accused of this, whereas
guilty people will do some of the things you're
saying or kind of react in other ways because
it's genuinely infuriating to be accused of
something that you just you just didn't do.
Speaker 5: Yeah.
So so I think that's really important, which
is it's not that you don't feel the fury or
the indignant.
So so being transparent about that even as
you are simultaneously being transparent about
what is not true.
Right.
Let me also say that this is related to most
difficult conversations, because we're often
having the conversation because something
is wrong.
Yeah, right.
Something has gone wrong.
Somebody screwed something up.
Somebody did or said something.
That's a problem.
And the and blame is a feature of most of
those conversations.
If it's not explicit, it's implicit.
Like, you know, we need to talk about the
fact that you don't seem to know how to run.
Zoom right.
Use your microphone.
What is wrong with you?
And and if the purpose of the conversation
is actually to fix the problem, blame is often
not helpful because it's basically saying,
let's talk about why you're the problem here.
I'm the good guy and the victim and you are
the person who screwed it up and is incompetent.
Right.
And it's not surprising that not many people
really want to be part of that conversation.
Like, no, thank you.
I don't want to be in that play with that
being cast in that role.
So so part of what we talk about, if you're
actually trying to problem solve is shifting
to talking about joint contribution like what
do we do or fail to do that got us where we're
at because I'll tell us what we need to change
if we're going to fix the problem and not
have it reoccur right.
Or should the same place next week, that's
a little bit different than the political
situation that you're talking about because
they're not actually trying to solve a problem.
Speaker 1: No, it's usually about trying to
to appear as though you got one over on whoever
else you're speaking to or whatever the case
may be.
And that's really at cross-purposes with much
of the productive ways to have these conversations.
I mean, it's interesting, because 80% of political
speech in the United States is sort of structurally
not even designed to achieve anything.
Speaker 5: Well, what it's actually designed
to achieve is not a conversation with the
other side.
Right.
It's a conversation with your face, right?
Yes.
So.
So you are saying it because you think it
is going to persuade or influence someone
or something.
It's just not what we're pretending it is
across the aisle or across party lines.
Speaker 1: When it comes to when you're in
the middle of some kind of tense exchange
and this could be a debate I'm having on my
show with someone who disagrees with me or
someone talking to their mom about whatever
they said or, you know, whatever the case
may be.
Oftentimes, there's this the emotion kind
of blocks your ability to really think.
And then after the fact, you often say, I
knew so many other things that I could have
said, but I didn't say, etc..
How how can you stay kind of level headed
during these exchanges?
Speaker 5: Well.
So I would I would distinguish between being
emotional.
And sharing emotion.
Speaker 2: Hmm.
Speaker 5: Because I would argue that you
in those exchanges, you've actually got two
layers of things going on.
One is the debate that we're trying to have
or the issues that we're trying to.
What?
Get one over on.
Yeah, you're right.
Or just better understand, sir.
Part of the advice is shift your purpose to.
Can we understand why we see this differently?
If we can shift from proving that I'm right
to.
It seems obvious that I'm right.
I'm just trying to understand why we see it
differently.
That's actually a productive conversation.
But you've got a second layer going on under
the surface, which is the emotions and relationship
layer that that is all about how I feel treated
in this exchange.
Speaker 1: Yeah.
One tool along those lines that I've been
told by a couple of different people is it
can be useful to say, okay, let's say the
topic is abortion.
I'm pro-choice, I'm talking to someone who's
against abortion.
Ask the other person why they believe you
are pro-choice.
To even see if they understand, even if they
disagree with your framework, how you came
to the conclusion.
And that, number one, it's good for everybody
to have the knowledge, but just the exercise
of it might put the person in a position that
we're just by even saying it, they might at
least be more willing to understand your view
if not agree with it.
Speaker 5: I think that that's right.
And what it highlights is that in any really
good conversation or attempt to influence,
by the way, you need two things.
You need high quality assertion that you share
your view with clarity and thoughtfulness
and etc., but you also actually need high
quality empathy.
Mm hmm.
That you are really listening generously and
deeply to each other.
To not to.
Because I think I'm going to agree with you,
but because in order to understand what might
be persuasive to you, I actually have to understand
what you think and why you think it.
Speaker 1: Yes.
Speaker 5: And then I can say, well, so here's
what it feels like is left out of your view
or that I worry about that it sounds like
you're not so worried about.
So talk to me about that.
So so when we talk about high quality assertion,
it actually has to be rooted in deep empathy
and and generous listening.
So the move that you just suggested is a clever
move, although it's basically backing the
other person into the corner to say, be empathetic
to me first.
Right.
And some people will take that and say like,
yeah, no, I actually think I can articulate
your view and that's helpful.
But if that doesn't work, it may be because
you actually have to do it first.
Right.
That you need to say so.
Let me see if I can describe what you're saying
and why you think what you think or feel the
way that you feel.
And then you can tell me what's left out of
that.
And then once they feel like you, you really
get it their view, then you're in a great
position to basically say like, okay, so let
me say a little bit about why I see this differently.
And I would love it if you could see if you
can summarize it back to me, because this
is just a complicated issue, right?
And that sense of reciprocity, which is one
of the most robust findings in the literature.
Like if you attack me, I'm going to attack
you back.
But if if you're willing to listen to me and
consider genuinely, authentically why I think
what I think or feel how I feel, well, then
I almost feel an obligation to do the same.
Speaker 1: Right.
So that would be like with the abortion example.
It might be, hey, listen, my my belief is
you're against it because you believe life
starts at conception so that any abortion
is is like a murder.
And but but but, Pippa, can you give me a
sense of why you think I am pro-choice?
And so I'm kind of doing it first, in a sense.
Speaker 5: Yes, you can.
Or you might even tweet question was say,
can you give me a sense?
And that's a genuine can you or do you feel
like you need more context from me in order
to understand that?
Speaker 1: Right.
Right.
Speaker 5: Because there's the.
There's the general view of why people are
on each side of this issue.
But then there's the you view like why do
you, David, care about this?
Speaker 1: Right.
Speaker 5: And often around these really important
hot issues, political issues.
One of the things that I hear is just differences
in what people worry most about.
Speaker 2: Hmm.
Speaker 5: So someone who is pro-life worries
most about the life of the child.
They would say child.
Speaker 1: Sure.
Speaker 5: And murder.
Someone who is pro-choice worries most about
other people making choices for individuals.
And what's interesting is that if we take
a couple steps back politically, Republicans
often worry most about individual choice and
government interference in individual choices,
which, of course, in abortion, that's flipped.
Speaker 1: Yes.
Speaker 5: Whereas Democrats often worry most
about the voices of those who are oppressed
and not in the majority and equity.
Right.
Or fairness.
And so often one of the the ears I have on
the conversation is whatever it is we're talking
about, what is it that each of us is worried
most about?
And in some ways, I don't have to worry about
what you're worried about because I know that
you'll take care of it.
Speaker 1: Right.
Speaker 5: If there wasn't anybody protecting
individual autonomy or choice from government,
I would have to worry about it.
But I can rely on you guys to worry about
it still so I can worry about something else
that actually matters to us as a society as
well.
Speaker 1: Super interesting.
We've been speaking with Harvard Law School
professor Sheila Heen, coauthor of The New
York Times bestsellers Difficult Conversations,
as well as thanks for the feedback.
Really appreciate your time today.
Thank you so much.
Speaker 5: Thank you.